cientos de personas de la comunidad de
myanmar en Sydney junto con partidarios
de la Liga Nacional para la democracia
protestaron este miércoles contra El
golpe militar en su país y la repentina
detención de
a principios de esta semana
no queremos el gobierno militar gracias
con pancartas y retratos de la Premio
Nobel los manifestantes exigieron la
liberación inmediata de todos los
detenidos políticos y pidieron que los
militares protejan al pueblo
queremos Instalar los líderes militares
de mian mara que respeten las leyes y
las normas democráticas
Les pedimos que lo respeten plenamente y
que acepten los resultados del 2020
también que dejen de proteger los
intereses propios de los militares
libertad el ejército de myanmar dijo que
había llevado a cabo las detenciones en
respuesta a un supuesto fraude electoral
entregando el poder al jefe militar e
imponiendo el estado de emergencia
Durante un año según una declaración
transmitida en una cadena de televisión
de propiedad militar el Primer Ministro
australiano Scott Morrison declaró el
lunes que las informaciones sobre la
toma del poder por parte de los
militares de myanmar eran
acontecimientos preocupantes